hi welcome to the reason stream I'm Zack
Weiss Muller joined by my colleague Liz
wolf hey Liz happy to be
here former president Donald Trump has
four separate indictments hanging over
his head at this point uh he also leads
the presidential Republican primary
field by a long shot in the polls and is
polling neck and neck with President
Biden most recently he pled not guilty
in the case originating in fton County
Georgia which of course generated this
now iconic
mugshot it is safe to say now that
whatever the outcome it's going to be
ugly partisans on both sides have rather
predictable positions on the Trump
prosecutions but on this show we aren't
partisans we're Skeptics of government
power Vigilant about the threat of
authoritarianism wherever it originates
and the direction from which those
threats originate I'm sad to say are
many these days so joining us today to
help assess those threats and determine
the best path forward from the
perspective of those of us who believe
our country is at its best When
government is limited to securing our
liberties and government officials are
held accountable for their misdeeds is
ilas San he's a law professor at George
Mason University the Simon chair in
constitutional studies at the KO
Institute and a writer at the vulet
conspiracy a legal blog that's hosted at
reason.com
there and elsewhere he's argued
forcefully for the prosecution of Donald
Trump for his actions following the 2020
presidential election and we'll get into
those arguments very soon Ilia thank you
for joining us today thank you very much
for having
me we're gonna focus on the election
interference cases and put aside the
Stormy Daniels case and the classified
documents case for the purposes of the
stream and we are live today and we do
plan to take audience questions if you
have them so start putting them in the
chat if so but let's start with the
discussion of the Georgia case since
it's the most recent filing and in many
ways it's the most expansive case what
are the key differences in the Georgia
case distinguishing it from the federal
trip uh Trump indictments there are many
differences but I would just focus on a
few of the most important ones uh one
big one is that the Georgia case unlike
the federal case features 18 additional
defendants besides Trump uh which
includes some very familiar people like
John Eastman who were key figures in
well-known people in the sort of
national conspiracy to overturn the
election but also a number of sort of
local Georgia figures that at least up
until this point I had not heard of and
I bet most of our listeners also had not
heard of so that's a big difference it
makes this case more complicated and
more sprawling than the federal W it is
likely that there will eventually be
separate Federal indict IND ments
against some of the uh un unnamed
co-conspirators that are listed in that
uh indictment but even though they're
unnamed in the indictment we know who
very likely who they are uh a second big
difference uh is that this is State
rather than Federal uh so it's a
somewhat different do related body of
Law and it's worth noting that state
charges cannot be pardoned uh by the
president of the United States uh he can
pardon federal charges though there is
dispute over whether a president could
pardon charges against himself uh that's
a long-standing disagreement among legal
Scholars about that issue uh but uh even
if Trump were to become president again
after the 24 election he could not
pardon these State charges uh and then a
third big difference is that uh in
addition to a number of charges which
look similar in some ways at least to
federal charges like charges about fraud
uh and uh and charges that relate to
sche mes about fake collectors and the
like that are cast as uh in in form of
fraud against the government uh there is
also charges under Reco uh and not the
federal Rico that many people may be
familiar with from various cases against
organized crime figures but the Georgia
state version of Rico which in some ways
is similar to the federal one but in
some ways is different and I admit I'm
not a Reco expert uh not even on the
federal Rico much less the state Rico so
I don't know how to fully assess that
but it does seem to me that this is an
important feature of the Georgia charges
that is not present uh in the federal
ones though it is also the case that
some of the charges in the Georgia case
are essentially what I would call State
versions of the federal charges charge
about fraud uh and the like uh and you
might say it's unfair that essentially
similar conduct or in some case even the
same conduct could be charged in both
state and federal Court you can argue
this VI Double Jeopardy uh but the
Supreme Court has said several times
most recently just a couple years ago
that the so-called dual Sovereign uh
Doctrine means that it's not Double
Jeopardy if one set of charge about the
same thing is federal and the other is
State I happen to disagree with the
Supreme Court majority on that but
they're the ones who get to decide that
uh and not me could I jump in there so I
in prepping for this I was fascinated by
some of your writings specifically on
the double jeopardy issue um could you
unpack that a little bit what your
disagreement with that is um when when
did the Supreme Court hand down this
decision it was relatively recent right
so the roots of the uh Doctrine are not
recent this dual Sovereign theory has
been around for a long time uh but the
Supreme Court Supreme Court case but the
Supreme Court reaffirmed the idea in
gamble versus the United States which is
a 2019 decision uh it was a 72 decision
with both liberal and conservative
Justice is in majority but in descent uh
we had uh one conservative justice
justice Gorsuch and one liberal Justice
Ruth Bader Ginsburg I happen to agree
with many of the points those two
justices make uh but the Supreme Court
is an institution that decides things by
majority vote and I do admit uh as
Ginsburg and Gorsuch do that the Dual
Sovereign Doctrine was not simply a
product of the 2019 decision it had
longstanding roots and one of the
reasons why the majority affirmed it
wasn't part because of this
long-standing precedent so the basic
idea is that double jeopardy does apply
if the same entity like the same level
of government files uh the same charges
or essentially the same charges twice
but if it's different entities that is
one is federal in the other state then
the the theory is well they're not
really the same charges because even
though they're about the same kinds of
things and maybe even about the same
exact events uh it's still different
crimes uh and not the same crime because
one crime is created uh in this case by
the state of Georgia uh by statutes they
have enacted and the other by the
federal government
uh I've seen some arguments that this
Georgia case and this is coming from
people who do want to see Trump
prosecuted but they believe the Georgia
case should be brought up to the federal
level it should not be a state case do
you have any opinion on that so yes
another issue that this case raises is
the argument that this should be tried
in federal court rather than uh in State
Court as with Rico this is an area the
issue of removal that I'm not a true
expert on so what I say about it is
going to be very tenative and I admit
there could be angles that I am missing
uh so uh there is a removal Doctrine
which says among other things that uh if
a federal official is charged
uh with offenses that are really about
things that he did as a matter of His
official Duty uh then uh that then you
know the case has to be dealt with in
federal court or can be removed to
federal court at least if the defendant
wants it to be uh and this argument
applies to some though not all of the
defendants in the Georgia case obviously
Donald Trump can make this argument Mark
Meadows who was Trump's acting chief of
staff at the time has made the argument
they're essentially saying what we were
doing was related to our jobs as Federal
officials various other people who are
charged like John Eastman for example
and various people in Georgia these
people were not uh Federal officials at
the time so they can't make this removal
argument uh they you know they have to
be tried in Georgia if if anywhere in my
view and again it's tentative I don't
think this removal argument holds water
uh and that's true for two reasons one
is the president of the United States
and his staff have no role in organizing
and running presidential elections uh
that's by Design the founders created
that system that way be in part because
it would be an obvious conflict of
interest if the president had a role in
running the proceedings for uh his own
uh election or reelection uh secondly uh
even aside from that point uh things
like uh you know schemes to replace the
real electors with fake electors or to
pressure State officials to in effect
falsify vote counts these things are
Beyond any plausible definition of the
president's or his chief of staff's
official uh jobs and therefore it seems
to me that this removal argument is is
relatively weak but I admit again I'm
not an expert on this I could be missing
something if people are interested in
this there is a lot of commentary on
this issue by Scholars and other experts
from youi do know a lot about this
removal issue I do not like the uh trend
of people essentially proclaiming
themselves as insta experts on things
that you know they only first thought
about you know a few days ago or in this
case a couple weeks ago and uh therefore
I want to be very careful in what I say
about this particular issue but it is
obviously an issue in the Georgia case
in a way that it's not an issue in the
federal case which is from the beginning
in federal court uh and so removal you
know does not come up so you've very
forcefully argued that there is a a very
strong case for prosecuting Trump from a
deterrence perspective and a retribution
perspective perspective could you walk
us through why should Libertarians be
supportive of Prosecuting Trump give us
just the basics of that case and Z will
pull up some material to sort of support
what you're talking about sure uh so in
the piece that you reference I take a
step back and ask well why do we have
criminal punishment in the first place
and there are a number of different
kinds of answers that different people
give to that question uh and indeed
Libertarians don't agree among
themselves necessarily on this just as
non- Libertarians have disagreements but
the most common answers are retribution
and deterrence retribution is simply the
idea that some people deserve punishment
because they did something evil or
terrible committing murder rape assault
theft and so on uh and uh therefore uh
we punish them because they deserve it
not because necessarily there are good
extended consequences to punishment but
simply because it's the right thing to
do in itself in a situation where the
defendant has committed some
particularly heinous or reprehensible
act uh then deterrence is the idea uh
that we punish people uh to prevent
others uh from committing the same acts
in the future so on this Theory we
punish the murderer or the rapist or the
thief not necessarily because they
deserve it they'll make maybe they do uh
but because punishing them sends a
signal to other potential criminals or
potential perpetrators of the same act
that you know this is what will happen
to you if you do this uh and therefore
uh you know you shouldn't do it uh you
you should think twice before you do it
and hopefully you'll be deterred from
doing it I recognize not everybody
necessarily uh accepts either
retribution or deterrence and there are
some Libertarians who believe there
should be no criminal punishment at all
just as there some leftwing people who
believe that so if you believe there
should be no criminal punishment for
anybody and you reject both the
retribution Theory and a deterrence
Theory I'm not going to suggest that you
should support Prosecuting Trump anyway
I'm gonna there you you would have to
consistently say I oppose Prosecuting
Trump just like I oppose Prosecuting
pretty much anybody because I don't
think there should be criminal
punishment for anyone of any kind and
similarly there are some Libertarians
who argue that the system of Criminal
Justice should be replaced uh purely by
a system of Civil Justice and if you
believe that you won't be persuaded by
the uh criminal uh prosecution arguments
against Trump either that they would
face some interesting issues about
whether Trump should face civil
liability for what he did but if you do
accept uh the ideas of Retribution or
the idea of deterrence then there is a
very strong case for prosecuting Trump
for what he did uh in his efforts to
overturn the 2020 election uh through
the use of Fraud and the threat of force
uh because certainly in a de democratic
system one of the most reprehensible
things that any high official can do
particularly the president is attempt to
stay in power even after he lost an
election which in this case he very
clearly did and staying in power by the
use of fraud in this case uh you know
Finding fake electors or pressuring
officials to falsify vote counts and the
like that is very reprehensible and it
goes beyond merely just asserting that
you won the election even though you
didn't this is actually taking action
through the use of fraud to overturn it
and then of course instigating the
attack on the capital uh adds force uh
to fraud the purpose that was to disrupt
the certification of the electoral votes
so if anything is a reprehensible act
for a high official in a democracy that
deserves retribution this is a good
example uh and the same point applies to
deterrence uh that uh we it's very
important to deter High officials from
serious misconduct of various kinds is
actually more important than deterring
low-level officials or deterring private
citizens uh and given the enormous
potential benefits to a power hungry
politician of being able to stay in
power indefinitely even if he lose an
election in fact making himself dictator
for life or at least dictator for
another four years or the like uh it's
important for there to be severe
punishment for schemes like this so as
to deter future power hungry politicians
uh from doing the same kind of thing the
Trump tried to do some of what Trump
tried to do may be put down to just
specific aspects of his personality or
the circumstances that uh of the 2020
election uh but the desire to stay in
power as long as possible is one that's
not unique to Trump it's one that many
politicians have indeed a desire for
power is one of the main reasons why
many of these people uh want to be
politicians in the first place so if
you're a Libertarian and you're
suspicious of government power uh one of
the things that you should worry about
is politicians uh who try to keep
themselves in power indefinitely even if
they lose an election democracy has many
flaws from a Libertarian perspective
I've done scholarship on many of those
flaws myself so I'm not arguing that
anything Democratic is good uh but I
would say from a Libertarian perspective
or any more General liberal perspective
democracy is less bad uh than
politicians who get to stay in power
even if they lose an election because
democracy does provide some useful check
uh on the abuses of politicians even if
it's flawed and even if it does also in
some cases cause abuses as well so I
think there is a strong retribution case
for punishing Trump given the extreme
heinousness of the actions he undertook
and there is a strong deterrence case
because uh what he did is the kind of
thing that it's especially important to
deter and particularly when we're
dealing with the official who held the
most powerful office in the land if some
low-level flunk he did something similar
uh the need for deterrence might be less
uh and maybe the heinousness would be
less as well the the reprehensibility
would be less but uh with with Trump uh
given that he was the president uh both
retribution and deterrence uh are
particularly significant in this case in
a way that goes beyond even when you
know Ordinary People or low ranking
officials do something similar speaking
of penous action Zack do you have some
evidence uh some slides to go through
well yeah I mean and we're gonna get uh
as we advance in this conversation into
some of the replies to what you laid out
uh Ilia because I know you you've gone
back and forth with some Scholars on
this because when we're talking about
deterrence you know uh we want to
clearly establish here what what is the
behavior we want to what is laid out in
this case some of the critics would say
that the unintended consequences of this
could be that you are
deterring legitimate speech or
legitimate questioning of election
results where there there may have been
um fraud in play I don't think that was
the case here but um th those are some
of the concerns that we'll get into in
in a minute but first let's look at the
the the case the the actual case that uh
Georgia has laid out against Trump um
this is there's 41 counts there's 19 uh
defendants named H including Trump and
many of his lawyers Rudy
Giuliani uh you mentioned John
Eastman um act one that they zero in on
here is on the 4th of November which
would be election night 2020 When Donald
Trump gave a speech where they said he
falsely declared Victory and falsely
claimed voter fraud we have a clip from
that speech Let's Take a look at that
clip and then talk about it in the
context of this case we won states that
we weren't expected to win Florida we
didn't win it we won it by a lot
and it's also clear that we have won
Georgia
we're up by 2.5% or
117,000 votes with only 7% left they're
never going to catch us they can't catch
us but most importantly we're winning
Pennsylvania by a tremendous amount
of
we and all of a sudden everything just
stopped this is a fraud on the American
public this is an embarrassment to our
country we were getting ready to win
this election frankly we did win this
election we did win this
election so uh I should also note that
the the um the Georgia case the
prosecutors alleged that the speech was
actually drafted four days or some
version of it was drafted 4 days before
the election um I'll will be interested
to see if they present evidence of that
but how might that speech Ilia
particularly if there's evidence that it
was drafted in advance implicate begin
to implicate Trump in criminal
conspiracy so what I would say is no one
including the prosecutors in the Georgia
case claims that merely giving that
speech is illegal this is something that
is misleading in some of the criticism
is offer of the indictment that when you
have the listing of the acts the the
listing of Acts is not a listing of
things that the prosecutors say are by
themselves illegal rather that speech
which included a number of false claims
that we can talk about uh is just part
of the evidence indicating that Trump
had a broader scheme to overturn the
election result after he lost it and
indeed one that he began to lay down
even before the election that's why it's
important it was drafted ahead of time
because it's clear that he was going to
claim fraud regardless of how and by how
much he lost uh and you know there's
evidence of that but merely saying I was
the victim of fraud would not have led
to this indictment rather the statements
about being a victim of fraud false
statements uh were uh part of a scheme
that involved things that are actually
worry Weagle which is uh trying to
replace the real electors with false
electors pressuring State officials into
falsifying devote counts as in the
famous uh call with the uh with the
secretary of state Georgia where he said
well find me
11,780 votes which has happened with the
exact number of votes that he was that
he needed to overcome Biden's lead uh in
Georgia uh so uh this is similar to if I
merely say you know Bob is a scumbag and
he deserves to die that itself is
perfect we legal uh at least it's not a
criminal violation you know setting
aside possible claims of Lial or slander
uh but if I then proceed uh to tell my
flunkies you know go out and Black Bob
uh than the previous statement where I
say that Bob deserves to die could be
brought as evidence against me in court
evidence of the motive uh and plan that
I had to you know to have Bob killed and
the same thing applies to uh Trump's
statements alleging fraud and also to
Trump's plans that were clearly laid
down even before the election to allege
fraud uh in in in any situation where he
might lose it's worth going for a moment
if we have time on what was false about
Trump's statement uh and that is uh but
but we could do that or if you'd like to
move on we please do no lay it out for
us I think that would uh so it is true
that in some of the states that Trump
ended up losing on Election night he was
still leading in the account but that
was because of the so-called blue shift
uh where because Trump for many months
before the election had claimed that
absentee voting or mailin voting uh was
fraudulent or are suspicious many
Republicans believe what he said and so
Republicans disproportionately voted on
Election Day whereas Democrats as a
result disproportionately voted by mail
into many states which permit this and
therefore in States like Pennsylvania
and some others which first counted the
inperson vote and only later counted the
male vote initially uh Republicans
started out with a big lead but as these
other votes which were
disproportionately Democratic were
counted and there's nothing wrong with
counting them indeed it would be illegal
if they had not been counted an unfair
as well uh then uh what initially
started out as a a wead for the repu for
for Trump turned into a lead for Biden
and many experts predicted ahead of time
that this is what would happen given the
hency of of many Republicans to uh do
mailin voting uh which was a new thing
in the 2020 election before 20120
actually maale in an absentee voting in
many states was actually somewhat
disproportionately Republican but Trump
ironically himself was responsible for
the SE for the trend which led to the
perception that you know he had a big
weed which would somehow you know
undermine uh and uh really within hours
uh of that statement it became very
clear uh that in in that in these states
uh the eventual vote count would show uh
that Trump had pretty decisively lost he
ultimately lost Pennsylvania by think
something like a close to 80 or 100,000
votes
uh and he wased these other states uh
the swing states by many thousands of
votes uh as well uh and to be clear also
to be clear you know to the extent that
there were any irregularities with the
ballots and the mailin balloting the
Trump team did challenge this stuff in
court and I assume we are all in
agreement here that that's a totally
legitimate route to take and has done
before right Trum and his supporters
filed over 60 lawsuits uh challenging
the results in various states that
itself is perfectly legal though I think
it was somewhat abusive in a case where
the overwhelming evidence was that there
was no chance that the results would be
overturned but he certainly had a legal
right to do that and that wasn't a crime
uh and it's worth noting that Trump lost
all but one of those cases and the one
he won in Pensylvania did not come close
to overturning the uh large margin that
Biden had in that state and it's
important and this is relevant to the
criminal as of the case that he
continued his fake electure scheme and
other efforts to overturn the election
even after he lost all those cases uh
and even after it became clear from the
way those cases developed uh that he and
his supporters had no real evidence of
fraud on anything like the scale
necessary to change the result it's
correct hold on get me correct me if I'm
wrong here but is it also correct that
some of the judges overseeing and and
issuing you know rulings on those
lawsuits were in fact also Trump
appointed yes absolutely and indeed one
of the most eloquent and Powerful
opinions uh on this issue uh was written
by a third circuit Trump uh appointee uh
who you know he had nominated for that
position uh and it's worth noting that
in some of these State cases that were
brought in state courts uh many of those
cases were also decided uh by
Conservative Republican judges uh
obviously state judges not federal ones
and uh Conservative Republican election
officials in a number of these states
like Georgia also certified the results
Brad raffensberger the Georgia Secretary
of State uh whom Trump tried to pressure
in that famous or notorious call he is a
Conservative Republican he would have
been very happy to see Trump win the
state of Georgia but he knew that simply
wasn't the case given the margin of over
11,000 votes and given the lack of
evidence of fraud or other problems in
anything like the scale that would have
been necessary to overturn that margin
so it's not the case that only wio
judges heard these cases or only liberal
Democratic officials were involved in
certifying the results yeah Brer would
seemingly have every reason to um decide
to abdicate his responsibility and to
succumb to the Trump pressure but the
fact that he didn't is at least to me
that's been one of the really
interesting components of this case that
I think many of the Maga heads have not
really appropriately dealt with at all
yeah and I I agree with you you can say
well you know this guy's a rhino or he's
an establishment person or whatever but
if the only evidence that he's a rhino
is the very thing that you're
questioning then uh you know his
decision making this partaker instance
then you know that's a you know
relatively weak
argument the another key Moment In the
case we played the clip of trump at the
uh you know um on Election night we can
now fast forward to his speech on
January 6 in front of the stop the steel
crowd uh and uh react to that so let's
play that and then see how that and I
hope Mike is going to do the right thing
I hope so I hope so because if Mike
Pence does the right thing we win the
election all he has to
do all this
is this is from the number one or
certainly one of the top constitutional
lawyers in our country he has the
absolute right to do it we're supposed
to protect our country support our
country support our Constitution and
protect our
Constitution states want to revote the
states got defrauded they were given
false information they voted on it now
they want to recertify they want it back
all vice president Pence has to do is
send it back to the states to
recertify and we become president and
you are the happiest
[Music]
people so we all know what happened
after that how does that moment
potentially
strengthen Trump's
prosecutors so it doesn't strengthen uh
them as much as a number of other
moments in that same speech but
obviously here uh we have further
Evidence or there's much other evidence
of Trump's uh desire to push true in EO
scheme the eego scheme here is uh
twofold one is getting Pence to set
aside the results which Pence had no
power to do fortunately Pence himself
right we concluded that he didn't have
the power to do it and therefore did not
in fact try to do this second uh is the
effort to replace the actual electors
actually certified by the states with
fake electors who were not certified at
all uh the statement that he made there
which said where he said where the
states want to uh revoke or or change
results that is simply false none of the
states uh the state legislators or
certifying officials made any effort to
uh change their results or revok them
even if they had made such an effort by
this point it would still have been
illegal because it would have been
passed the deadline uh set by law by
which they had to uh uh submit their
electoral slates uh but the fact is that
no actual state governments tried to uh
change the you know Biden slates to
Trump slates what you had is essentially
you know Trump supporters who were not
actual uh State officials empowered in
this process you know attempting to uh
you know fraudulently insinuate fake
electors instead of the real ones um and
you mentioned there's other parts of the
speech that you find more damning could
you just summarize there's other parts
of the speech which I think strongly
suggest that he wanted to use
the violent threat of the crowd to
pressure Congress into uh denying
certification of the results uh these
are the pass the famous patches where he
says you should fight like hell and
Marsh to Capital and so forth uh and I
think this needs to be uh considered not
just in the context of what's in the
speech but also in the context of
Trump's previous encouragement and
endorsement of violence on a number of
occasions both during the 2016 election
and in 2020 when he for instance prayed
proud boys and others who attacked uh
people violently uh and uh it should be
viewed in the context of uh evidence
uncovered by the January 6 Commission in
Congress uh which said that when he
heard about the riot Trump actually
wanted to go to the capital and lead the
and lead the attack uh even though he
also was restrained by his Secret
Service agents from actually trying to
do this uh so I do recognize that
statements like such as fight like hell
can be metaphoric but in this case I
think there is strong evidence to given
the overall context to take them more
literally though I should emphasize that
the neither the Federal indictment nor
the Georgia indictment directly charge
him with inciting an Insurrection or
inciting violence but I do but they do
charge him with trying to use the threat
of violence uh as a way to leverage
Congress and we know that even while the
attack in the capital was going on he
was trying to call various senators and
representatives to try to get them to
deny certification of the results and to
use the threat of the riot or the fact
that the riot was going on as part of
his leverage uh to do so I would love to
move us to a few audience questions some
push back on these points that you just
made if that's cool um you know one one
commenter a blinkin says um most of the
cases were thrown out for lack of
standing the cases weren't even heard
what do you make of that is that
accurate that is not true some cases
were thrown out on procedure grounds but
about 30 about half the total cases were
decided on the merits either because the
court actually reached the merits or
because the court said well you the
plaintiffs either Trump or his
supporters need to present evidence uh
of of Fraud and they said no no no we
don't actually have any evidence of
Fraud and therefore they withdrew the
case for that reason uh so about half
the cases either ended up being
withdrawn by the plaintiffs because they
didn't have the necessary evidence of
fraud or were in fact decided on Dem
merits okay I I want to do two more um
really briefly uh I also really
appreciate that our commenters are you
know giving this type of push back
because I think you know so many
Publications out there and so many
journalists aren't interested in
engaging in this type of thing and like
I think it is important that we um
Steelman the the other side's argument
as best as we possibly can um one person
agar Riser says he wasn't asking for
Georgia to find votes for him he was
asking Georgia to find illegitimate
votes for jrb who I imagine is Joseph
robinet Biden as Matt Walch would say uh
what do you make of that the idea that
he was I think that I think that is not
true first the actual statement uh by
Trump is find me
11,780 votes uh which uh you know seem
to say you know fine votes for me but
also uh even if you interpret as
disqualified votes for Biden that still
is an attempt to uh pressure
raffensberger into an illegal scheme
give that by the time this call happened
first all of Trump's uh legal challenges
in Georgia alleging fraud had failed and
second no evidence of any largescale
fraud had been uh brought up and third
if you look at the transcript of this
actual conversation raffensberger who
was the official in a position to know
and as I noted earlier a Conservative
Republican he repeatedly tells Trump
that there's no evidence of large-scale
fraud or other problems and Trump
clearly doesn't care about that and just
says you know go find me to votes so
given the context uh I think it is very
clear that Trump was indifferent to the
question of whether the 11,780 votes
were going to be found legally or
illegally he just wanted those votes so
he could Prevail in Georgia let me bring
up a question that I I'd like to address
here from the audience from Josh lion
not even close to persecution holy cow
even proposing that as a legitimate
question is dishonest as hell uh I just
want to say that we are going to have
these conversations whether you like it
or not and other people are going to
have these
conversations the frustrating thing
about the past five years or or so has
been the attempts to re in what is
acceptable discourse and so I just
totally reject that that kind of frame
and um if people are upset by us you
know trying to have a Frank discussion
about one of the most important
political issues then I I don't know
what to tell you that's what we're here
for there's also a question uh for uh
ghost of Recon threw in $2 and said
presumption of innocence is missing in
his analysis um is that true Ilia I mean
I I assume presumption of innocence is a
standard that applies in court uh and I
totally agree that Trump should not be
convicted un W uh they can prove his
guilt Beyond A Reasonable Doubt however
in public discourse where what's at St
you know I don't have the power to send
Trump to prison or impose any punishment
on him all I'm doing is I is saying that
I think based on the overwhelming
evidence that is already in the public
sphere that I think it is in fact the
case that Trump is guilty of at least
many of these charges just as I also
think for instance that OJ Simpson was
guilty of murdering those two people
even though I totally agree uh that of
course he deserved uh the presumption of
evidence of Innocence in court and I
also agreed that my merely thinking uh
that Simpson was guilty of those murders
that that by itself is not enough to
send him to court and there's an
important distinction between uh what we
can conclude as a matter of seeking the
truth in public discourse and legal
standards that must be met in court uh
before somebody can actually be sent to
prison or indeed subjected to any kind
of criminal punishment can before we
move before we move on to the the next
section which is going to be responding
to some of the other criticisms that
you've dealt with and people you've gone
back and forth with il I just want to
say thank you to wishes Network for a $5
donation I don't think there was a
question attached to that but uh if you
have one throw it in later go ahead l oh
I was just gonna ask could you play that
Matt Whitaker clip
Zack uh sure it's a really sad day for
our country I mean if you believe in the
rule of law and if you believe in equal
justice under the law this should
concern you uh because you know we have
what appears to be a completely
political prosecution of the former
president the current leader for the
Republican nomination and you know it is
uh was a rush to get him indicted you
know you look at the other cases compare
this to Hunter Biden's case Joe Biden's
case vice president Pence's and even uh
you know Hillary Clinton and and I just
I can't see how the Department of
Justice isn't explaining why they're
doing this case and none of these other
cases that I just mentioned it's it's
really a sad day Harrison and I and I
think it's uh it's the stuff of banana
republics quite frankly so I am
fascinated by this because this is
something we keep hearing from so many
Trump uh lackes and boosters uh and
people in the media frankly uh and
you've written really forcefully Ilia
that actually the Banana Republic
talking point is totally Incorrect and I
was doing a little bit of digging into
this and you actually look at the degree
to which other um you know countries
hold their former leaders accountable
for crimes um after they leave office I
mean we see this with Netanyahu we see
this with um Nicholas sarosi with Sylvio
bascone this isn't just the stuff of you
know banana republics this is something
that decent democracies in the developed
World actually frequently do and frankly
as a Libertarian I mean I would maybe
like to see more people in positions of
power held accountable for um things
they do wrong things criminal things
that they do in an office how do you
respond to the Banana Republic talking
point IIA in two ways one of them you've
already done for me which is that many
wellestablished respected democracies
have in fact prosecuted current or even
for current or former heads of
government or heads of state just wised
some of them France Israel the prime
minister of Israel is under indictment
for various crimes right now uh and
South Korea uh the former president was
removed from power and she was
prosecuted for corruption and I believe
I can't remember off hand but I think
she spent time in prison uh so uh
countries which pretty obviously are not
banana republics do this on a regular
basis uh but secondly if there's one
thing that is Banana Republic It's a
president uh who is who tried to stay in
power despite losing an election part of
what goes on in the Banana Republic is
that even though we have the forms of
democracy we don't have the reality
because the person in power can in fact
falsify the
or use force and fraud to stay in power
even if he loses and that's the kind of
think that Trump attempted to do and if
we want to keep from becoming a Banana
Republic or at least reduce the chances
of doing so we have to uh inflict
retribution and deterrence on high
officials who do this sort of thing uh
even if uh uh and indeed it's
particularly important to impose
punishment on them especially given that
uh we would without hesitation impose it
on low-level officials or private
citizens who tried to do similar things
uh I want to also comment if you have
time on first who Matthew Whitaker is
and second uh some of the other
statements he said regarding Biden
Hillary Clinton and like Matthew
Whitaker is not a neutral objective
Observer Matthew Whitaker was Trump's
acting attorney general uh after Trump
got rid of Jeff sessions his first
attorney general why because sessions
Alo a very right-wing Republican with an
ideology pretty similar to Trump's own
and MAA populist he was unwilling to go
along with some of Trump's illegal
schemes and the like so Whitaker was
made acing attorney general because
Trump assumed that you know Whitaker uh
would be willing to do this sort of
stuff and he only remained acting
because Trump uh likely calculated that
Whit Whitaker could not be confirmed
even by what was then a republican
controlled Senate that doesn't by itself
prove that the things he's saying are
false but it does suggest that this is
not a very credible person uh what he's
saying regarding uh Biden and Hillary
Clinton uh with the case of Biden it is
true that Biden like Trump uh is under
investigation for possibly holding on to
classified documents when he shouldn't
have and indeed uh the justice
department appointed a special counsel
uh a former Trump official no less to
investigate Biden's retention of
classified documents and if that special
Council determines that charges are
warranted maybe at some point they'll be
filed uh you can tell a similar story
about Hillary Clinton's email server if
you believe that's a crime that should
be charged uh then among the people
responsible for failing to charge it are
actually the people in the Trump
Administration who had four years to
file charges in that case if they
thought it was warranted uh and yet they
didn't uh but none of this stuff is on
the same plane as trying to use force
and fraud to stay in power after you
lose a presidential election
neither Biden nor Hillary Clinton
despite I think some real sins and
arguably abuses of power that they
commit in other instances none of them
did something like that so uh there is
no double standard on that and on the
classified documents again uh both uh
Trump and Biden uh had been investigated
by a special councel uh on that and uh
the special councel in investigating
Biden uh you know is simply taking
longer on that it's unlikely that he's
taking longer to help Biden given that
that special council is a US attorney
previously appointed by Trump if
anything it might actually be worse for
Biden if charges end up being filed
against him close to an election rather
than uh the investigation being
completed uh earlier than that and to be
clear uh the Matthew Whitaker clip was
him talking about the uh classified
documents case but you hear the Banana
Republic Canard often uh in in relation
to all these cases another uh CR line of
critic You Hear Comes courtesy of Rand
Paul's tweet here where he says one way
to destroy a Democratic Republic is to
criminalize speech when will Democratic
supporters of the First Amendment step
forward uh and the article that he links
here is headlined the criminalization of
politics to get Trump is endangering
everyone's speech what is your reply to
that concern that we are in danger of
making any sort
of push back or speeches about uh
electoral issues a crime yeah the
response is simple no one including
Trump is being prosecuted simply for
saying the election was fraudulent or
simply for saying Trump uh deserved to
win the election those are false claims
but they are not violations of criminal
law and they should not be rather what
Trump is being prosecuted for and others
as well is for uh not merely speaking
but planning and taking action the
scheme to in to replace real electors
with false ones to pressure State
officials in some cases also to defraud
the courts placing false evidence in
court and the like uh and it is true
that part of what's involved in these
schemes is speech but that can be said
for any kind of criminal conspiracy if a
Mafia Boss tells one of his underlings
you know you know I don't want to see
Joe around anymore let's Whack Him you
can say well that's just speech uh but
of course it's speech that's part of an
effort to produce action and that makes
it different from a mere expression of
political opinion or uh any kind of
opinion uh and I think there it's
important not to conflate a situation
where speech is being prosecuted purely
because it expresses some kind of uh
wrong or uh objectionable opinion and a
in a case where speech is part of a plan
of action and is being prosecuted for
that
reason a more substantive I think uh
critique of the case for prosecuting
Trump comes from Jack Goldsmith uh who
you've engaged with in writing before
he's a former AG for George W bush he
published this oped in the New York
Times called entitled The prosecution of
trump may have terrible consequences and
he's making the reason I find this more
persuasive in a way is that it's not
really even trying to make the case that
Trump didn't do something wrong or you
know that he he uh you know legal
legally isn't culpable but he's kind of
taking a more pragmatic approach and he
what he says here also is that this is
all happening against the backdrop of
perceived unfairness in the Justice
Department's earlier investigation
originating in the Obama Administration
of Mr Trump tr's connections to Russia
in the 2016 general election also the
perceived unfairness in the Department's
treatment of Mr Biden's son Hunter uh he
goes on these are not what aboutism
points they're in the context they're
the context in which a very large part
of the country will fairly judge the
legitimacy of the Justice Department's
election fraud prosecution of Mr Trump
now uh you know so for me there there's
an deal in which politicians face the
same justice system as the rest of us
and then there's the reality in which
the doj and the FBI undermined the first
half of the Trump presidency with a
Russia collusion case that did not pan
out put all sorts of backdoor pressure
on social media and the lead up to the
2020 election to suppress content under
the guise of misinformation and then the
timing of all this is just terrible
especially with the federal case going
to trial right before super Tuesday it
all makes me more sympathetic to the
argument that even if Trump in some
Cosmic sense deserves prosecution that
there's no way it's going to do anything
than further degrade the legitimacy of
the institutions of justice that we as
Libertarians want to have legitimacy to
do things like secure our liberties by
administering Justice what is your
reaction to that Ilia yeah so Jack
Goldsmith is a more serious and
substantial figure certainly than Matt
Whitaker who was quoted earlier and his
concerns deserve to be taken seriously
nonetheless I think he's largely wrong
the biggest thing on which he's wrong
about is he simply doesn't consider uh
the weighty points on the other side
which is what will happen if Trump is
not prosecuted for this stuff and is
allowed to get away Scott free first of
all uh that will incentivize other
politicians perhaps including also Trump
himself to do similar things in the
future future if you can lose an
election and try to stay in power by
force and fraud and it's a freebie why
not go ahead and do it and you know the
worst will happens your scheme will fail
uh but you won't suffer any uh
punishment for it that's a terrible set
of incentives and it's awful uh and
that's a much greater risk than any of
these scenarios that um uh Goldsmith
posits secondly would respect to
perceptions of legitimacy he has a lot
of solicitation for the feelings of
trump supporters and their perceptions
but what about the rest of us and what
we will think about the legitimacy of
the justice system if a person is able
to get away with this kind of behavior
in this kind of criminal abuse of power
merely because he's a prominent
politician uh and his supporters are
likely to get mad if he's prosecuted and
convicted uh that will certainly degrade
uh the uh legitimacy of the justice
system in the eyes of the roughly 60 to
70% of the population who do know that
Trump commit uh uh lost the election and
who believe that he deserves prosecution
uh for uh you know his actions at that
time uh so if you're looking at judging
these things by public perception and
public reaction and it may be that we
shouldn't do that at all but if we are
going to judge that way then we should
consider the whole public and not merely
the trumpus public uh and the rest of us
matter too and these people because of
their false perceptions should not enjoy
a veto power uh I also dispute some of
what gold smith said about
uh you know some of the previous
investigations in the Wake well it is
true that uh they did not find quote
unquote collusion between Trump and
Russian agents uh there was good reason
to investigate him for that because
there was a lot of evidence of contact
between Trump campaign officials and
various Russian agents the mower report
weighs this out and break the tail uh
and as for Hunter Biden well In fairness
this hadn't happened yet but we just in
the last couple days uh heard the
announcement that he will in fact uh be
charged and very likely uh prosecuted uh
you can argue he should be prosecuted
more and that there's some double
standards there that could well be uh
it's nowhere near on the scale of Trump
trying to stay in power despite losing
an election and using force and fraud to
do so so the fact that officials or in
this case relatives of high govern
officials can get away you know with
some smaller scale RS that would not be
forgiven Ordinary People that's a bad
thing and we should criticize that uh
that in no way justifies uh letting
Trump get away with something far far
worse than anything Hunter Biden is
charged with okay but for Trump
supporters and some non-trump supporters
which I I'm not a trump supporter but it
is you you do you do get the the feeling
given the timing of this given kind of
the the constant investigations that uh
Trump has has been under that it's the
the attitude from the beginning has been
like we're going to do we're going to
throw whatever we can at this guy to
stop him from you know staying in the
presidency or getting elected again what
it like just in a practical sense what
is why not let this play out um in the
political Arena rather than in the halls
of Justice uh you know that there was
the chance to impeach him which the
house did then the Senate did not
convict um there's The Ballot Box why
not just leave it to the uh leave this
in the realm of politics for three
reasons two of them I've already
mentioned before retribution and
deterrence he deserves retribution and
we need to deter future officials from
engaging in the same kind of behavior uh
and the political process by itself
cannot do that uh especially in the case
of Retribution uh third uh it is makes
no sense to say we're going to rely
purely on the political process uh to
deal with schemes whose very purpose is
in fact to undermine that very process
the whole point of Trump's scheme to
overturn the 2020 election was to stay
in power even after he lost to Short
Circuit that process and therefore uh
the process by itself uh is not
sufficient to deal with a scheme that if
it's successful would actually destroy
that very process additional mechanisms
are needed uh to deal with that uh and
criminal prosecution while not the only
possible mechanism is an important one
uh that stands a good chance of being
effective what do you make of I think
one of the arguments that people sort of
frequently conflate is you know Trump
has been persecuted by you know the
court system by by people bringing you
know lawsuits against him but also that
Trump has been persecuted by much of the
media and that the The Narrative
surrounding Trump has sort of been pred
decided ever since he uh came down that
escalator and announced his original his
initial bid for presidency there has
been just a ton of aggressive animist
directed his way and I think sometimes
like I'm sympathetic to the argument
that he's been persecuted in some ways
and treated very unfairly by much of the
media but not sympathetic to the
argument that uh that is the case in the
court system I think it is absolutely
heinous what he did in terms of
attempting to uh cast doubt on the
legitimacy of the election based off a
very flimsy evidence I think it's
important for that evidence to be weigh
but as we discussed before I mean you
know those 60 cases that were considered
and the 30 of which were actually judged
on their merits the fact that only one
turned up any sort of substantial
evidence um and and 29 of them did not
proceed and did not find any evidence I
think is uh super super compelling what
do you make of sort of trumpus argument
that like there has been such
persecution before all of this happened
and it it leaves such a sour taste in
their mouths where they're not totally
sure that he'll get a fair Shake do you
think there's any validity to that yeah
so I think your distinction between the
court in the media I think is is largely
right in that when cases have been filed
against him in court he has been uh
treated fairly indeed probably more
fairly than sort of an ordinary person
would have in some of these cases in
that for instance right now uh if an
ordinary person was charged with the
kinds of things that Trump was charged
with and then made the kinds of comments
about po poal jurors that he has made
implicitly threatening them there's
likely that the ordinary person be in
pre-trial detention rather an outree uh
and also that at the very least he would
be required to post very Hefty bail
which Trump uh for the most part has not
been required to do uh and the same
thing I think is true in the Civil
system where various civil lawsuits
should be filed against him I think with
Trump as with any prominent politician
there are some claims made in the media
about him which are unfair and untrue
that said I'm not actually all that
sympathetic to the argument that he's
been persecuted by the media overall
even though there are certainly
particular media claims that have been
made I think are are likely wrong uh and
that is if you want to complain about
people being mean to you uh my answer in
the case of trump is uh you you reap
what you sow when you see how Trump
talks about his opponents uh or even
people within his own party that
disagree with him in various ways uh he
certainly is not civil he doesn't fairly
weigh evidence indeed he appeals to all
kinds of bigotry and Prejudice uh of
various kinds uh even in such things as
his attacks on uh the uh on elain chow
the wife of Mitch McConnell for the fact
that she's uh of Chinese background uh
you know his uh advocacy of racial and
ethnic and religious bigotry and the
like so if you want to be treated nicely
by other people A good rule of thumb is
treat those other people the way you
yourself want to be treated uh Trump
very obviously we doesn't do that uh so
it stands to reason given his uh
complete unfairness to his opponents uh
that other people are going to regard
him negatively and sometimes yes be
unfair to him uh as well uh but but he
has done plenty to justify uh the fact
that he gets a lot of negative media
coverage I think we'll have to agree to
disagree on that one I don't know I
think that this is definitely almost a
subject entirely worthy of its own live
stream at some point sure but uh the a
like apoplectic way with which so many
members of the mainstream media writers
of the New York Times And The Washington
Post have heralded the rise of Donald
Trump and then I think also the way they
reacted to coid and the pandemic at
least for me as both a journalist and a
news consumer I felt a certain um
distrust in many of these people to
remain uh even keeled and levelheaded in
their portrayal of what was going on um
but that's you know a bigger complaint
that I think we can get into some other
time uh Zack did you want to move to
yeah I want to um you know start to
bring this conversation to a close by
examining the other aspect of the
Georgia case which we mentioned the 18
alleged co-conspirators mostly his
attorneys like Jenna Ellis Rudy Giuliani
and John Eastman who was the
intellectual architect of that elector
scheme that Mike Pence rejected um it's
a scheme that was laid out in this
Sixpoint memo that was released
um I've highlighted a couple sections of
this including one aspect is that Pence
would gavl in Trump uh as reelected
after um kind of rejecting one slate of
electors for another and then Force the
other side to fight to to fight to fight
it out in court so going on a sort of
offense and point six here he says the
main thing here is that Pence should do
this without asking for permission
either from a vote of the joint session
or from the court let the other side
challenge his actions in court
Eastman recently appeared he appeared
last week on Laura anging show on Fox
and this is what he had to say in his
defense you know the people that I was
representing had a right to counsel and
what's going on here with the Bar
complaints against everybody involved in
any of the litigation this Fulton County
complaint the unindicted co-conspirators
in the federal action they're trying to
stifle people from being able to get
representation in election challenges if
if disputed questions of constitutional
law all of a sudden become criminal we
we could we could uh throw you know the
entire legal profession the entire legal
Academy in in jail now the fact of the
matter is throughout our history uh
significant uh leaders in Congress have
have argued that Congress doesn't have
Authority Under the 12th Amendment that
the founder specifically designed it
that way so that the president wouldn't
owe his job to Congress it's a core
separation of powers principle that the
founders adopted and he just doesn't he
ignores that uh in his analysis so the
notion that this is well settled is
crazy is bringing the attorneys into
this case criminalizing dissent and
criminalizing the uh profession of law
as Eastman suggest here IIA in a word no
uh because what Eastman and some of the
others were doing here went beyond
simply giving legal advice it was
participating in urging a scheme of
e-legal Conduct in this case as you
highed in that memo trying to get pens
to illegally reject the electoral votes
uh and the like and there's many cases
involving Mafia lawyers for example
where when the lawyer doesn't merely
advise his client and sort of how to
defend himself in court or something
like that but in instead uh you know
participates in a scheme for for illegal
action you know lawyers can be
prosecuted for that and this is far from
the first time uh that this has happened
to be sure there can be cases where
there's gray areas as with many legal
doctrines in this case with Eastman and
so of the others I don't think it's that
much for a gray area because Eastman was
clearly urging the specific plan uh that
was uh adopted here uh he wasn't me even
merely saying like you know somebody
else wanted TOA plan and they asked
Eastman whether it would be legal or not
uh you know Eastman went beyond you know
something uh like that so uh if uh you
know a mafia lawyer advises uh his you
know his Mafia client that you know we
should we should kill this person and
not only that but it would be legal to
kill him because it would just be
self-defense or something like that uh
you know the mafia lawyer could be
prosecuted for that and he couldn't hide
behind you know the idea that he was
just giving legal advice uh that you the
planning of future crimes uh is one of
the uh standard exceptions to attorney
client privilege and one of the kinds of
things that historically lawyers can be
and have been prosecuted for when they
engage in it okay but isn't that kind of
an extreme metaphor you know he he
wasn't uh uh advocating anyone be killed
he his argument is that this is a
legitimate
contested area of constitutional
interpretation you you just agree you
just disagree that this is in any way a
valid way to interpret the Constitution
so his argument was extremely bad but uh
this is going Beyond merely making a bad
argument in the abstract this is urging
a specific course of action and planning
it out uh and uh I don't think it's at
the comparison to Mafia is all that
extreme when you recognize the dire
horrible consequences of what would have
happened if this scheme had succeeded
that is that a president would have been
able to stay in power despite losing
election uh that's you not exactly the
same thing as as carrying out a murder
uh but it's nonetheless a large scale
awful
crime one of the things that worries me
a little bit about the sort of sedici
seditious conspiracy rapper around this
is how far that can be extended I mean
we're already we're roping in attorneys
who are advancing these legal theories
or courses of action um you know the the
Sedition charge has been used to
prosecute and sentence to decades in
prison actually know there is no
sedition charge in any of these
cases okay that there's a cons but it
okay so there's a conspiracy charge
there's a there's the RICO charge okay
and then we can say that you know the
Sedition charge is a
separate charge that's been
uh applied to the the January 6 rioter
um who are now some of them are facing
decades in prison some who were not even
there I I'm I'm worried that this
approach this expansive approach is
handing unbounded power to suppress
descent to whichever party controls the
state should I be worried about that uh
I think in this particular set of cases
no uh when you talk about the January 6
people yes some them weren't there but
those who weren't there were ones who
were involved in the planning of the
attack on the capital they weren't
merely people who just said the election
was illegitimate or the Trump really won
into like they were leaders of
organizations like the oathkeepers and
the proud boys who were directly
involved in the planning of the attack
so if you're involved in a planning of a
violent action uh you can certainly be
charged with that uh even if you weren't
personally present there uh and uh on
the uh breath of a conspiracy you know
as I said before I'm not an expert on
Rico uh but uh when you're looking at
people like Eastman these were people
who are in the Inner Circle of planners
specifically planning out the specific
actions regarding fake collectors uh
rejecting the uh the plan to have Trump
reject the ballots and reject the
electoral votes and so forth so these
are not people with some far out
indirect connection to the plan these
were essentially the planners themselves
uh you the Georgia case admittedly I'm
not in I'm not familiar with all the
details of all the indictments of the 18
different people so perhaps you can find
someone among the 18 who was much
further removed than Eastman and if so
we can talk about whether you know it's
a good idea to charge that person or not
but with someone like Eastman and other
uh people closely involved in the
planning I think you know there's no
great slip res slope risk indeed there's
a s pre swaped risk the other way if you
let PE these people get off simply
because they're lawyers are to like uh
because then that creates an obvious
incentive to use Warriors to uh plan
your uh schemes to uh stay in power so I
want to end on a note uh that is sure to
make our viewers and commenters extra
incensed extra angry um and that is the
sort of controversial uh Section 3 14th
Amendment approach to possibly keeping
uh Trump off the ballot in this upcoming
election um it essentially uses his role
or attempts to use his role in January
6th um as a means of ensuring that he
has kept off the ballot in many states
uh section three I believe was actually
something um that was added in the wake
of the Civil War basically when you know
the the nation was uh so terribly
divided and then came together after
that uh and was attempting to move on
there there they felt the need to
stipulate uh that those who had been
involved ined in Insurrection or
Rebellion uh should be
ineligible uh what do you think I mean
you've supported this pretty publicly
Ilia um what do you make of this this
case do you think this is I I think
there's two questions here there's is
this prudent to do and um is this
correct to do like there's a pragmatic
side and then there's a principal side
how do you look at this yeah so I think
there's two sets of issues here one is
whether the legal argument is correct
that issue is sufficiently complicated
there's no way I can do it justice uh
and I've have not tried to do it justice
rather uh um uh I if you're interest
this there's a long and detailed article
by Michael Stokes Paulson uh and will
bod to prominent conservative
originalist Wego Scholars who have put
out the article in the University of
Pennsylvania Law review and I urge
people interested in the legal side it
is to look at that uh in my recent
lafare article which you just uh posted
I look at the moral and pragmatic side
of this uh and uh I argue there uh that
there are good reasons sometimes to
disqualify people from elections in a
democracy who are a threat to democracy
itself Pro as proven by their track
record there are parallels from other
democracies particularly in Germany and
Eastern Europe and I also criticize
various kinds of slippery Swope
arguments uh that have been made against
this but I do admit that some Swip res
considerations should be taken seriously
and I even raise one that uh I think
hasn't been much discussed which is that
uh the text of the 14th amendment in
section three does not distinguish
between insurrections for just causes
and insurrections for unjust causes I
think what happened on January 6th is
pretty clearly an unjust cause uh but
the by the same reasoning would would
disqualify a person who had participated
for instance in John Brown's
Insurrection against slavery at least if
that person had been previously a
federal or state official
uh so uh while I think there are some
reasonable concerns about section three
unbalance I think using it is Justified
and dis instance uh and I lay out that
those reasons in more detail in the
laare article uh and also does it even
count as an Insurrection or is it like a
failed Insurrection right I mean the Q
and on Shaman was not exactly uh
wondrously effective in his stated goal
right so you can have an inter an
interraction can exist even if it fails
there's no requirement that it be
successful okay understood um I are
other sorry there are other questions
about whether this counts as an
Insurrection and ding her address very
thoroughly in the article by bod and uh
and Paulson uh but the fact that it
failed does not count uh against its
being an Insurrection indeed the
rebellion of the Confederacy which
inspired section three also ultimately
failed the Confederacy was crushed but
not that didn't Venter from being an
Insurrection yeah I I just have to ask
ier since what is being proposed here is
essentially that state legisl or you
know state election officials could pull
Trump off the ballot and said he's he's
not uh under the 14th Amendment he's not
allowed to run
here that just strikes me on a a a
practical level as that is a potential
Tipping Point you know people talk about
uh Civil War and everything and I think
lot of that's overblown but I think the
the kind of blowback from that sort of
move strikes me as like kind of horrific
to contemplate does that not worry you
so I think it would be legitimate to
worry about this if State officially
just do this on their own without any
outside review but in fact there would
be judicial review of decisions like
this in both state and potentially
federal court as well uh and including
of course by in the federal courts by
judges appointed by Trump and other
Republican presidents I think there's a
good chance ultimately this issue would
go to the Supreme Court if the argument
is well regardless of whether this was
done by through courts or not or
regardless of judicial review that
Trump's supporters might react with
violence my answer is that the threat of
violence uh should not deter us from
doing what is right if doing this is
otherwise right which I recognize you
know there's an argument about that but
if it's otherwise right to do if we
allow the threat of violence to DET us
then that just incentivizes more
violence uh and just as you shouldn't
give in terrorism you shouldn't give in
uh threats of violence in this kind of
situation either I am very concerned
about the slippery slope argument but I
personally oppose the section three plan
with regard to Trump I'm in favor of it
specifically applied to V ramaswami
because I think uh his assault his
Insurrection on my earlobes with his
Eminem wrapping attempts uh definitely
means that he ought to be disqualified
from being sent to sees into letter to
him so you
can you can stand Eminem a little bit
for that yeah I think we should section
three VC uh not Trump but uh we really
appreciate you taking the time to speak
with us Ilia San uh where can people
find you sure so they can Google me and
find my website also as you mentioned
before the VOA conspiracy blog V K which
is on the reason website wonderful thank
you so much for taking the time to speak
with us we really appreciated it thank
you for having me great questions
and we'll be back next week uh same time
same place